what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight Theory video I wanted to do
something a little different for today's
video but I have to say a few things
first before I get started
the theory I'm about to present to you
is not one that I created and I'm not
exactly sure who originally made this
theory but after I read it I thought it
was pretty damn interesting and I
haven't actually heard this one before
which doesn't happen often because I am
aware of damn near every Theory out
there but someone sent me an email and
had an article attached to it with this
theory and I read most of it and I don't
recall anyone ever talking about this
before so I figured I would present this
to you because I'm curious to see what
you think about it the chances of this
coming true or probably pretty slim but
the idea was so interesting I didn't
want to completely disregard it if you
would like to read this full article
while we'll put the link down in the
description of the video
but if this theory comes true it could
mean for one hell of an ending a very
sad ending I must say the two
showrunners Dan and Dave have won on
record saying there is one major
shocking moment or twist remaining in
this series and they said it would
happen at the end of season 8 no one
really knows what this final shocking
moment will be but many people believe
it's gonna have something to do with the
night king what this theory suggests is
this could mean there is going to be
some deadly consequences for the Starks
when and if they kill the night king now
let me tell you why during season seven
episode six we learned something pretty
interesting about the night king we
learned that when you kill their leader
the rest of them will fall - when Jon
Snow cut through the white Walker with
his Valyrian steel sword it
simultaneously killed all of the whites
who were following him except for the
one they captured of course but
nonetheless when you kill the leader the
others will fall then beric Dondarrion
points out that if you kill the night
king his entire army should die - but
doesn't that sound almost a little too
simple could it really be that easy or
is there some kind of a twist to this
what if the night King has a deeper
connection to the Starks than any of us
have ever thought and if he dies they
all die - I know it sounds crazy but
let's have some fun
according to old nan the 13th Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch was a
legendary figure known as the night's
king and she believes he was a stark and
it kind of makes sense when you think
about how the Starks have this
connection to the old north and the cold
we know the Starks can withstand the
cold temperatures more than most of any
of the other characters we have met and
we also know the Starks had an ancestral
Valyrian steel sword called
ice which does sound eerily similar to
the weapons the White Walkers and the
night King uses the Starks are also
direct descendants of the first men who
did coexist with the children of the
forest and in the show we learned that
the children on the forest were the ones
who created this night king that we know
today so I don't think it's out of the
realm of possibility that the children
on the forest could have used a Stark to
create the night king I know some people
always want to get hung up on the man's
hair color but I wouldn't let that
change your mind not all of the Starks
have the same hair color the night's
king from the books was also known to
have had a night's queen living with him
at the wall and together they started
making babies they started to give these
babies to the others as sacrifices but
what if some of their babies weren't
given as sacrifices could the Starks we
know today be descendants of the night's
king who was a stark in this Nights
Queen that would mean they would have
blood of the first men and the others
and that could be a way to explain why
the Starks have this connection with the
others it would also explain why they
have some resistance to the cold and why
they would name their sword ice Catelyn
Stark once said that the name ice has
been passed down from sword - sword
the Starks Valyrian steel sword is not
their first one called hice they have
reused that name for hundreds or even
thousands of years I think it is pretty
clear that the night King they created
has a very strange connection with bran
stark plus you can't ignore the looks
John and the night King have exchanged
sometimes the night King looks at John
almost like he knows him the night king
has also had multiple opportunities to
kill Jon Snow but for some reason he
since there is also something else that
happened in season 7 episode 6 that
could be foreshadowing this tragic end
but it could also be reaching to when
beric Dondarrion suggests that killing
the night king will kill them all he
then tells John that the Lord of Light
must have brought both of them back for
a reason and that's when the Hound says
every Lord he has ever known was a [ __ ]
and he says the Lord of Light probably
isn't any different right after the
Hound makes that comment the scene then
cuts to his scene with songs of stark so
think about what happened right there
this theory suggests that that could
have been a hidden message
John was brought back by the Lord of
Light to kill the night King but the
Hound suggests that the Lord of Light is
a [ __ ] just like every other Lord
that could mean yeah the Lord of Light
did bring John back to kill the night
king but there is going to be a catch
could that be the reason why the scene
immediately switched to John's family
right after they had this conversation
maybe or maybe not
how tragic would it be if John
unknowingly killed his entire family
when he kills the night king and to top
it all off what if brain stark ends up
finding out this information but he
keeps it a secret because he knows the
night king needs to be defeated
regardless of the consequences I know it
may sound crazy to some of you but I
thought it was an interesting idea and
it's nice to see some fresh theories out
there even if they are covered in tin
foil I'm not so sure if they would ever
do something like this in a television
show but I could definitely see george
RR martin adding some kind of
devastating twist at the end of his
story and if Dan and Dave are going to
stick to George RR Martin's ending we
could see something similar in the show
I have no idea what their final shocking
moment will be but I think we can expect
just about anything
the Starks definitely have some kind of
strange connection to the others and I
think it would be pretty damn tragic if
John killed the night king and all of
the remaining Starks did die but like I
said at the beginning of this video I
did not create this theory I just
thought it was pretty cool and worth
mentioning check out the link in the
description if you want to read the full
thing the person who wrote it connected
some other thoughts that I left out of
this video anyways thanks for stopping
by to check this out let me know what
you think about it what
you think the final big shocking twist
will be they said there would be three
moments that would shock fans and they
already did two of them according to the
showrunners I know I'm very anxious to
find out what this last one could be
before I go I have to thank everyone on
patreon who continues to support the
channel I really appreciate all the help
you have given me have a great day
everyone
I will see you in the next one bye
[Music]